invention fever grips Los Angeles the
only major threat to Kennedy's hopes his
Senate Majority Leader Lyndon Johnson
delegates to meet with Kennedy right now
backer bomb teddie crisis places in best
in a surprising upset senator john
kennedy has won the West
what hey you mind if I ask you a
question Lennon you are your damn money
jack all the Liberals hate it we need
southerners just no power in the vice
presidency power use where power goes
guess you knew Kennedys don't do a lot
of here huh John Kennedy has been
elected president of the United States I
need to show strong record when civil
rights from the start they might listen
to what other know who's on our side
what makes you think he's on our side
one of those Kennedys must really hate
you those Hobbit boys not going to tell
us how to run the state of Georgia
you're gonna lose the support of the
people have always had your back this
train is leaving the station you can hop
on the whit man try to slow the damn
thing down if I'm gonna make a run in 68
I'm gonna need people like me shut the
door
how could anybody not like him
we've got Martin Luther King writing
letters from a jail cell it's an
embarrassment around the world you
submit this bill now it will never
become law what are we waiting for
a new leader has emerged America has a
southern president you don't waste any
time do you Lyndon excuse me
rather not have it didn't have it
[Applause]
Kennedy is a man of great ideas now the
country needs a man you can deliver
there will be no compromise
this is about making President Kennedy's
vision
reality
this will define your presidency I can
only hope
[Music]
you